the number one thing that has made us
successful by far is one of the
interesting things about being an
inventor is you don't go to school for
it
there isn't an inventor class you can't
major in inventing every problems I met
in my when I was a kid
benefited me wanna be happy build a life
not a business
every single day we'll be running it out
so loving you and I believe in life for
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn the best lessons from
billionaire entrepreneurs let's kick it
off with lesson number one focus on your
customers with Jeff Bezos the secret
sauce of Amazon where there several
principles at Amazon but the number one
thing that has made us successful by far
is obsessive-compulsive focus on the
customer as opposed to obsession over
the competitor and I talked so often to
other CEOs and some other CEOs and also
founders and entrepreneurs and I can
tell that even though they're talking
about customers they're really focusing
on competitors and it is a huge
advantage to any company if you can stay
focused on your customer instead of your
competitor
listen number two take risks with Elon
Musk one of the most difficult choices I
have ever faced in life was was in 2008
and I think I had make up maybe thirty
million dollars left thirty or forty one
dollars left in 2008 I had two choices I
could put it all into one company and
then the other company would definitely
die or split it between the two
companies and but if I split it between
two companies then both might die and
you know where you put your blood sweat
and tears into creating something a
bully something it's like a child
and so it's like which one am I gonna
let one starve to death I can bring
myself to do it surprised I split the
money between two what's really thank
goodness they both came through also if
you want to learn how to have more
confidence check of my 254 series
they're free the links aren't in
description below there are times when
if something is important enough you
believe it enough that you do you do it
in spite of fear when I was selling
copiers door-to-door I had a very clear
vision of what my life was gonna be like
if everything has to work in two to
three years
then that limits what you can do lesson
number three
believe what Sara Blakely you famously
started Spanx with $5,000 in your bank
account what was the hardest part about
getting Spanx off the ground the hardest
part about getting things off the ground
was definitely in the very beginning
when you have when you first have an
idea as an inventor and you thought of
something that doesn't exist and you
want to bring it into the world there
were two things that were happening one
was my own self-doubt was a really hard
part of the journey and and then the
beginning of all the manufacturers that
I was having to cold call and talk to to
try to get my product made we're all men
and it was much harder to explain and to
try to get them to understand the
concept of what the product was so I
heard the word no for two straight years
trying to get it made which then
increases the self-doubt that can happen
and one of the interesting things about
being an inventor is you don't go to
school for it
there isn't an inventor class you can't
major in inventing and so it's really a
belief system in yourself and the
willingness to look stupid or to have
people laugh at you or to fail at
something that you believe in your your
own gut check on that and so it takes a
lot of confidence so that was that was
the hardest part of my journey there was
a lot of starting and stopping and like
am I crazy and everyone's saying no and
but I you know I kept picking myself
back up to pursue it
lesson number four never give up with
Jack Ma it's a young boy I never thought
you know it's a young boy if ever today
I never thought I would be here honestly
I never thought but as a young boy I
probably when I look back every problems
I met him by when I was a kid
benefited me I filled so many times
people probably know that I'm applying
jobs for so many jobs over 30 jobs all
rejected not even got a chance 24 of us
are interview for a care
seek job 23 accepted I was the only got
rejected five six people went fuller
looking for a police job five except I
was the only one my cousin I applied job
as a as a server in a full style to my
city we wait a long queue for two hours
he was accepted I react so my mother
looked at me huh you know yes but I know
this is a training course for me before
my thirty years old I'm a failure of
people lose by never give up I think
there is opportunity there and then I I
was a teacher later I bred from
University I was teaching the universe
for six years number five because number
five year I was elected the best a
teacher of my universe elected by
students so I said everything I taught
my students are the things I learned
from books what if I go out spend a ten
years experience all the things whether
fail or succeed I'd go back to teach
again that was my original thing and
doing Alibaba so I never thought I could
be rich I never thought it would be
successful I never thought we could
survive for 18 years and then we made it
listen number five be determined to
succeed with Warren Buffett I would like
to tell you of two women Oh
that each sold the business to Berkshire
Hathaway to me actually for many many
many millions of dollars both of them
started with $2,500 by a coincidence was
the exact same Amato is everything they
had in the world and one of them was a
woman who landed in Seattle in 1917
couldn't speak a word of English Hanna
Tague around her neck the tag said Fort
Dodge Iowa
the Red Cross got hurt afford Dodge
where she was reunited with her husband
who'd come to the country a couple years
earlier and she lived in Fort Dodge for
two years and as she put it she felt
like a dummy she couldn't pick up the
language and she couldn't learn a word
and so she decided and she and her
husband decided to move to Omaha so they
came to Omaha in 1919 and there she
found a small colony of Russian Jews so
she started feeling more at home and
then as her oldest daughter went to
school she would come home this daughter
Frances and she would teach her mother
the words that she learned in school
that day and this woman rose bumpkin
spent 20 years saving money bringing
first her siblings over her mother and
father fifty dollars at a time she sold
used clothing to do it she had four
children during this period and by 1937
after 20 years
she saved $2,500 she went to Chicago and
she bought what she put a furniture her
dream had always been to open a
furniture store and this woman but I
would never gone to school one day in
her life with $2,500 but with the same
spirit that the people in this room had
about having a dream and working to
accomplish that dream she built a
business which she sold me in 1983 for
60 million dollars approximately in
which which did a billion and a half
dollars worth of business last year the
fourth generation is working in that
business
this woman rose blumpkin lived well she
she worked for me until she was 103 and
now then I'm not said and she retired
and she died the next
which is a lesson to all of Berkshire's
managers in premature retirement nothing
you can't tell what's going to happen
but mrs. b-but their $2,500 one further
fact about her she could not read or
write and she went into a furniture
business and she didn't bring anything
in unique in furniture but she brought a
determination to succeed she knew she
could outwork anyone else she knows she
cared about her customers she worked in
Murray low gross margins but she built
this incredible business and lesson
number six the last one before a very
special bonus clip is know who you are
with Oprah Winfrey for me the
foundational base of empowerment of
entrepreneurship of any kind of
engagement the foundational base of my
success of my well-being my wholeness my
everything is knowing who I am and where
I come from in my living room right now
is a painting that I've owned now for 30
years you can google it it's called to
the highest bidder and it's at the
center of my house and it's at the
center of my house because it actually
is symbolic of the foundation of not the
house but the foundation for my life the
painting is by Harry Roslyn who was a
genre painter painter in the early
twentieth nineteen century and the
painting is over six feet tall and it
shows a slave woman on the auction block
holding her daughter's hand and I cannot
come in the door my front door or I
cannot leave without passing that
painting I am reminded of where I come
from every day of my life and I am
reminded because I never want to forget
it and in my library I have a frame list
of
enslaved African American people
remember I showed you who were held in
bondage on various plantations listed in
the Ledger's alongside the cows and the
horses and the buggies and the other
property and I passed this list every
day and often I stopped in front of it
and just speak their names out loud and
their ages Jonah's eleven years old
five hundred dollars Sarah forty-one
years old nine hundred dollars Elizabeth
fifty seven eight hundred dollars and I
forced myself to consider the absurdity
and the obscenity of prices being
affixed to each one should they be
placed up for sale and I sometimes just
pause before them with a prayer
particularly before I have to make a big
decision about one of my companies or
whether I booth forward or whether I
stay still it reminds me speaking those
names out loud not only of where I've
come from but how far I have to go
because of them and it reminds me that I
am never alone it reminds me of what
I've come through to get through I've
got a special bonus clip with Mark
Zuckerberg on how to create change that
I think you're gonna enjoy but before
that it's time for the three point
landing questions let's go from just
watching a video to taking action here
we go question number one how can you
better focus on your customers question
number two what risk do you need to take
this week and number three what can you
do to believe in yourself and your ideas
more to me entrepreneurship is about
creating change not just creating
companies and you know the most
effective entrepreneurs that who I've
met it care deeply about some mission
and some change that they're trying to
create and often they don't even start
because they're trying to create a
company all right and you know that's
how I think about you know my connection
to tell all of us here is you know I was
getting started I am and I want it I
care deeply about giving everyone a
voice right and giving people the tools
to share everything that they cared
about and bringing a community together
and you know it started small and in one
University and I didn't think it was
gonna be a company at the time as a
matter of fact I was pretty convinced
that at some point someone would build
something like this for the world but
you know I thought that that would be
some other company that you know already
had thousands of engineers and was used
to building stuff for hundreds of
millions of people around the world and
you know what ended up happening was you
know that no one built it right so we
just kind of kept on going right I mean
people said it each step along the way
you know what you're doing all right
maybe college students like it but no
one else is gonna like it and you know
there's not gonna be any money in doing
this so all right so you only really do
it if you care all right if you're
passionate about doing it then it's
start growing and people said it would
be a fad and it would never be a good
business but you know you keep going
because you care not because you're
you're trying to create a business and
you know then there's the shift in
mobile where people thought that you
know it wouldn't be a sustainable
business and you know it through each of
these things you the entrepreneurs who I
think build things that last for a long
time keep going because they care
fundamentally about the change that
they're trying to create in the world
and they're not in it just to build a
company
if you want to learn the lessons of Elon
Musk Warren Buffett and other
billionaire entrepreneurs check out the
video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there if you want to be
successful learn from the other people's
mistakes don't learn from the successful
stories